as if the pandemic hasn't upended life
enough some parts of the US are now
bracing for the biggest weather threat
so far of the spring season a powerful
storm cell unleash lightning and hail in
southwest Texas Friday flood warning
stretch from California to the deep
south tornadoes and damaging winds are
expected through Monday with the most
severe weather likely on Easter Sunday
meteorologist Jeff Baer Adelie joins us
with the nation's weather Jeff good
morning that does not sound good
good morning Michelle yeah we need to
take this threat very seriously as you
said especially on Sunday but even today
in Texas we're gonna see severe weather
the possibility of a few isolated
tornadoes let's start out by showing you
what's gonna be happening and why this
is gonna be such a significant outbreak
of severe weather we have a strong
Jetstream right now an area of low
pressure has been spinning around in
California that is going to be ejecting
to the east as it does so it's gonna
invigorate a very strong subtropical jet
stream with winds aloft over 100 miles
an hour at the surface the Gulf of
Mexico right now is really warm four to
eight degrees above normal that's gonna
supply a lot of warmth humidity and
instability all right let's show you our
by our what's gonna happen storms
developing this morning in Texas as we
head through the day the worst of it
could be Dallas down to around Houston
after that that's gonna move to the east
and look at what happens in Texas
another surge of severe weather that's
the one we're really concerned about
during the day on Sunday
lots of thunderstorms supercell
thunderstorms possible it could be long
track tornadoes be very very careful
make sure you pay attention to any
warnings that are that are issued from
the National Weather Service and the
other side of the storm is to snow and a
lot of snow
we could see 6 to 12 inches in parts of
the Upper Midwest maybe even more than
that watch out in places like
Minneapolis that's the swath of snow you
can see it right there is a lot of heavy
snow on the way one other thing I want
to mention to you is there are likely
gonna be tornado warnings in the
southeast shelters are likely to be open
but I know a lot of people may not want
to go because
kovat 19 if a big tornadoes headed
towards you you have to have a plan
today back to you guys in the studio
okay Jeff we're not in the studio one
one in the studio here and Michelle and
Dana at home but I'm good that's right
thank you very much